on a des révélations sur encore la ferc
et salah qui continue puisque nouvel
avocat de christian quesada n'hésite pas
à prendre la parole dans les médias pour
défendre son client
il fait des révélations étonnantes à
chaque fois regardez vous a préparé un
petit récap dans les colonnes du journal
le progrès l'avocat de christian quesada
apporte de nouvelles révélations sur son
client notamment sur la prise de
conscience de ces dérives qu'il aurait
tenté d'enrayer il ya plusieurs années à
l'époque où ketsana avait déjà été
condamné pour des faits similaires il
aurait pris la décision d'avoir recours
à un processus psychiatrique pour lutter
contre ses démons
il a poursuivi des soins avec un
psychiatre parce qu'il sentait son mal
être
à un moment donné il a pensé qu'il était
guéri et il a rechuté il va chercher à
comprendre et à se soigner
si christian quesada est en prison il
continue de suivre la télévision et les
différentes choses qui se disent à son
sujet ils étaient prouvés et scandalisé
par ce qui se raconte sur lui mais il a
un profond sentiment de culpabilité et
il veut rétablir certaines vérités pour
lui les accusations que la jeune mélissa
a formulé sont fausses cette jeune femme
était venue témoigner d'une agression de
la part de christian quesada il invité à
boire un coup dans un bar il n'a touché
à la cuisse berne et par qui son avocat
précise il conteste fermement la notion
de contrainte de surprises et de
contacts à connotation sexuelle
en plus cette jeune fille a dit des
choses différentes à deux reprises si
l'avocat songe à déposer une demande de
libération provisoire christian quesada
est toujours en prison en attente d'une
date pour son procès alors on a d'autres
infos encore jack layton qui sadaoui ce
qui est très intéressant c'est le choix
de l'avocat au début il y avait un
avocat pour christian quesada commis
d'office et là et après un cabinet de
bourg-en-bresse dans l'ain
pourquoi il est resté là bas il n'a pas
pris un grand pénaliste de paris c'est
parce que sa stratégie c'est de dire je
ne suis pas christian quesada dans une
procédure le joueur de paris le
millionnaire etc
je suis christian quesada de hauteville
dans l'ain et je ne veux être jugé que
sur ça c'est une volonté de sa part de
minimiser la faire j'ai pas si ça va
marcher mais c'est sa stratégie
judiciaire d'accord oui costil
et oui justement la première avocate
qu'elle avait m savournin était
spécialisée dans le droit de sociétés
dont celle de quelqu'un je vis à vis du
pénal
et c'est intéressant de voir ce que dit
le nouvel avocat parce qu'il veut
atténuer sa culpabilité mais prévoit une
responsabilité lorsqu'il dit oui mais
voilà j'assume ce qu'il a fait et c
mais lorsqu'il dit qu'il l'a déjà été
soignée pour pédophiles pour papa pompe
et de philosophie et de pornographie
j'ai été soigné à plusieurs reprises ça
peut être contre productif parce que s'y
tiennent
a été soignée et que tu as rechute et ça
peut être contre-productif donc il faut
qu'il fasse attention damas qui dit on
va suivre ça et si vous avez d'autres
infos nistelrooij et une dernière info
ils ont évolué longtemps gardé le
silence mais à un moment les avocats et
leur client dit c'est plus possible on
et l'horloge se disait même si on est
trop salie c'est trop fort il faut qu'on
parle mais ce n'était pas leur stratégie
de départ ils ont été contraints par
toutes les révélations qui sont sortis